los créditos más caros en dos décadas el
Banco Central europeo elevó a 3,5% su
tasa de interés intentando atajar el
alto costo de vida en consecuencia los
bancos europeos pagarán más por sus
depósitos en la banca central lo cual se
trasladará a un mayor costo de los
créditos a familias y empresas con la
medida se busca frenar las salsas que
afectan los bolsillos de los
consumidores
los riesgos del alza para la inflación
incluyen posibles presiones alcistas
renovadas sobre el coste de la energía y
los alimentos también relacionadas con
la guerra de Rusia contra Ucrania Un
aumento en las expectativas de inflación
por encima de nuestra meta o aumento
superiores en salarios o los márgenes de
beneficio también podrían impulsar la
inflación al alza en Europa los
intereses no habían estado tan altos
desde 2001 y aunque la inflación sede
sigue siendo muy alta por ahora no se
ven las condiciones para congelar ni
bajar los intereses
pero en lo que respecta al Banco Central
europeo dije lo que dije hemos subido
las tasas de interés a menos que haya un
cambio continuaremos subiéndolas en
nuestra próxima reunión Así que no
estamos pensando en hacer una pausa
en un hecho inusual el aumento de
intereses se da Después de que la
reserva Federal en Estados Unidos
decidiera no ajustar sus tipos de
interés a futuro El Banco Central
europeo está resuelto a subir más las
tasas hasta controlar la carestía